вони просто беруть документи ідуть у
військкомату І стоять в черзі а їм
кажуть так Зачекай трішки Давай пізніше
ми зараз з чоловіками розберемося а
потім будемо ні от я чула Реальні
історії коли дівчата просто домагалися
того щоби
щоби їх взяли на контракт і вони поїхали
саме в цьому бойових дій до 24-го числа
є дівчинка яка була танцівницею
професійної і хореограмом постановником
дуже красиво танцювала Така тендітна
балерина
зараз вона в аеробіці вже більше року
вона навіть не приїжджала в відпустку і
на ротацію не їздила то дуже багато
таких
глибоких дуже творчих
дуже таких незламних дівчат які
які роблять дуже складну роботу маючи
сім'ю